oh it's that time of year that time of
year in which I make a video that gives
people who don't watch my videos and
probably a few who do that existential
crisis as they try to wrestle with how
does this person have this as their top
10 films of the year and I know this is
the part where I'm supposed to say this
is just my list it's my very subjective
list this is my opinion all film is
subjective but in my experience such
disclaimers don't really help all that
much so yeah I'll just say this is the
most objectively accurate top 10 films a
2022 list that you're gonna see before
we get to it I will say that these
aren't reviews of the movies just so you
know I do have reviews of all the movies
on this list it's just going to be a
brief like hey this is it this is why
it's on the list maybe this is why this
is placed where it is on the list and
then we move on I think it's time is
money let's not waste both yeah better
things to do than hear me prattle on for
too long so here we go now we go
number 10.
starting at this list I always like to
have one film on here that's a little
unorthodox to be on a top 10 list
something that personally hit me
something that I just really enjoyed and
maybe it's because I still got the
Christmas spirit because he just binged
a lot of Christmas movies this week but
violent night is on here dude it's Die
Hard meets Home Alone meets the Santa
Claus what's not the like Not only was
it absurdly entertaining but I start
getting excited when I see what they
could do with sequels like with every
John Wick sequel how the world expanded
you see more and more absurd things and
mechanics of how this underworld works
that we don't even know operates in our
world you can do that with mythical
characters and creatures among Christmas
and other holidays I can see the
possibility of this gaining a cult
following as the years go on one thing I
know is I will enjoy adding this to my
yearly Christmas binge list number nine
next we have the whale this is actually
a little tough because there's some good
movies that come out this time of year
they're making that Oscar push I watched
this movie less than a week ago so maybe
it'll move up the list as time goes on
all I know is as I watched it a week ago
it's here on number nine it's a powerful
character piece with amazing acting from
the entire cast fact is when a character
piece like this has me fighting back the
tears in the movie theater because they
don't want to be a sobbing mess in the
middle of the movie theater I just
seriously consider that film for the top
ten number eight shoot next up Avatar
the way of water the reality is I have a
very different relationship with Avatar
than what feels like the rest of the
internet but I enjoy it this was a solid
return to Pandora technologically
speaking it's Leaps and Bounds above
everything else but man honest 2022
which is kind of a dark year in general
I'm not even just saying globally I'm
saying personally it was it did its job
and it did it well it did what movies
like this are supposed to do which is
get you to forget about all the other
[ __ ] out there that's not on the big
screen right now it was amazing escapism
number seven next up 2022 promised to
bring us a Multiverse of Madness and it
brought us a Multiverse of Madness in
everything everywhere all at once this
was a heartfelt family film that could
have felt like low budget MCU this has a
few we'll say quirky mechanics that
could have made the film fall flat but
it it made it work also the action was
great it's a fun action film there are a
few surprises on this list this was
definitely one of them number six next
up Pinocchio the Guillermo del Toro
Pinocchio that is I heard we got three
pinocchios I only remember one other one
that might be on another list I do but
when guillerama Del Toro is coming out
with a new film you pay attention when
he's coming out with a fairy tale film a
very familiar fairy tale film in which
you've heard the origins of that fairy
tale or well they're much darker than
you know it as you can't help but put
that on your must watch list this film
was dark tragic but also beautiful not
just because of its stop-motion
animation which that is but also its
execution it's concept it's mythology
also the voice acting was incredible I
forgot to mention that in my review I
believe because I got so wrapped up in
the stop-motion animation in the
atmosphere of the film poignant it all
came together and it was a beautiful
thing
number five okay so this next one's a
film that got a lot of Internet buzz and
then one of the critics at the
screenings that I go to he had seen it
and I was like is it is it good because
it's like three hours long I just want
to know what I'm in for and he said rrr
is everything you go to the movies for
personally like you Jeremy you so I
watched it and I was like well he wasn't
wrong this is pure 90s action movie
style amazing in all the best ways 2022
was the year that a lot of people in
America gave tollywood love like people
who didn't before funny thing about this
is they've always gotten the impression
that people in India were like they saw
the hype surrounding rrr and they're
like this is what you're losing your
minds over we got better but that's the
cool thing about it it Sparks the
Curiosity people go down the rabbit hole
of tollywood films experience a bunch of
stuff they wouldn't have experienced if
rrr had not gotten the hype it got
saying that is all beside the point of
the fact that rrr in and of itself was
just an enjoyable time and it's the kind
of film that I hope makes Hollywood
sweat or they're like what totally
worked as competition for us
impossible no it's not impossible at all
and I like that number four next up this
is a film I enjoyed when I watched it
but as time goes on
um I've watched it multiple times since
and I just appreciate it more as the
year had gone on well that's the Batman
I'm just explaining it without actually
saying the title it's the Batman yes
it's 2022 generally gave us comic book
movie vomit as the year was going on the
Batman's the only comic book movie of
the year that I felt tried to elevate
the genre tried to do something special
something more dramatic with it and a
large part succeeded battenson isn't my
favorite on-screen live-action Batman
I've ever seen but this is my favorite
on-screen live action Gotham I've ever
seen the support cast was incredible the
atmosphere was straight up out of the
Arkham games I want to see more from
this world but I want to see things that
we haven't seen before dude Supreme
Court of owls bring whatever point is
great atmosphere great musical score as
well number three
next up this is probably the biggest
surprise of the year because I didn't
even know this movie was existing was
going to exist it just kind of came out
and I was like all right I'll watch this
movie and wow the menu was awesome never
saw trailers knew nothing about it so me
being surprised as this film went on was
just part of the experience for me the
foodie and me loved the presentation the
horror Thriller fan in me loved the
experience I ended up getting 2022 was
actually a really good year of horror
Thriller some surprisingly good stuff
coming out of that genre but the menu
kind of embodied everything great about
the surprise of sitting down and
watching a great Thriller there's an
experience I loved and I've told
everybody I know like dude you should go
watch the menu right now number two next
up another film that you can't help but
just appreciate the more the year went
on is top gun Maverick I was not looking
forward to top gun Maverick when it was
coming out I was like a sequel to a 35
year old film we all know how this is
gonna go down right because we've seen
this go down and it's not good turns out
when it's made by people who love the
characters and the world well it can be
pretty great it had Nostalgia as icing
on the cake but it didn't rely on that
it didn't rely on the icing of the cake
to be the entire cake still gotta make a
great cake that has icing on it top gun
Maverick did that and yeah it was
heartfelt I teared up in a scene I will
say it's more about Maverick than the
Ensemble but it's Maverick right it's
like top gun Maverick is the embodiment
of the concept of Field of Dreams if you
build it they will come
number one
and there have been some great films on
this list well I feel they're great
anyway but there's only one film this
year that had two naked dudes fighting
on a volcano in the name of Vengeance
80s metal album cover style and that's
the Northman funny enough and I tell
people there's a conversation out there
in the world off the YouTubes the
northman's probably the most digestible
Robert Eggers film out there in terms of
appealing to a broader audience like if
I wanted to get people into Robert
Eggers films I'd probably start with the
northmen I wouldn't start with the
lighthouse or the witch I could see how
that might be a little off-putting for
some Robert Eggers die hards out there
but for me I thought this film was great
Norseman thought well it has North
missile
try to say that again Jeremy Norse
mythology but it's always when he's
having a fever dream or tripping balls
so you don't know if it's real or not
just kind of keeps that in line with the
mythology but also the mindset of the
people of time it's a Revenge film that
doesn't give you that yeah everyone got
wiped out and revenge and revenge is
good but it doesn't undercut it either
by the end like he's still going for it
it was a heavy film set in a brutal time
it doesn't shy away from any of it and
this is a film that got its hooks in me
it got its claws in me early in the year
and it's like it's the film that I
measured every other film after it up
against I probably shouldn't do that but
I kinda did I would just be like I like
this one was it as good as the
northman's still number one maintain
that feeling all the way to the ends to
this video so that's my list of my top
10 movies my favorites of the year but
hey more importantly than me vomiting my
10 favorite movies of the year I want to
give a thank you to all of you you keep
this channel going you have kept it
going for over 13 years now it's
actually a comment and the thing I I run
into people and they're like dude I used
to watch you in elementary school I
graduated college now it's mind-blowing
to me but it's also really cool and very
appreciated I want you to know that I
don't want you to watch the videos and
be like you think he gives a [ __ ] like I
do I do care I care and I appreciate
that fact because without you watching
my videos there's no me doing this I
would be I'd be a projectionist at a
movie theater still I got lucky because
you good folks out there were like I
like what this guy's given I guess I'll
keep watching I want you to know that
I'm very aware of that I'm very
appreciative of that fact and you but
now you've heard my top 10 list of the
year what is your top 10 list if you
haven't seen enough movies to have a 10
do a five do a three do whatever it
doesn't even have to be movies you can
do video games if you like you know I'm
a gamer whatever you think comment below
let me know and as always if you like
what you've seen here and you want to
see more click right here to see more
[Music]